back in 1995 when I wrote Fingerprints
of the Gods I was searching around for
many possibilities that could have
caused a global cataclysm in the range
of 12 to 13 000 years ago because that's
what all the astronomy pointed out 12 to
13 000 years ago and hapgood's Theory uh
seemed to me a very valuable and useful
one I still won't write it off I won't
dismiss it entirely but I've shifted in
the direction of um the younger driest
impact hypothesis simply because I'm in
a constant argument with mainstream
Academia and the issue to me the most
important issue to me is the issue of a
global cataclysm at the end of the Ice
Age what what caused that cataclysm is a
secondary issue the cataclysm itself is
the primary issue and I found the
younger dryas impact hypothesis a better
much more scientifically grounded
explanation for that cataclysm than the
notion of Earth crust displacement but
do any archaeologists or any of these
prehistorian dispute the younger dress
there's a there's still a lot of
argument around it there's there's about
60 major scientists
um who are involved in the comet
research group they're all credentialed
scientists they've all published dozens
of papers in peer-reviewed journals
including nature including scientific
reports and many many others on the on
the hypothesis but there's also a group
of academics who are opposed to it and
and uh dispute that any impact ever took
place and then even in those who who do
accept that the younger dryas was a
cataclysm some think that it may have
been caused by solar activity rather
than by by comet impact how would that
work well it would certainly it could
work
um at the end of the younger dryers
there are two moments in the younger
dryers the beginning is twelve thousand
eight hundred years ago it's a very
strange moment in Earth history this is
when
um this is this is when the world's
climate which has been warming up for a
few thousand years the ice age is still
very much present have big ice caps on
North America big ice caps on Northern
Europe
um but it's been warming up gradually
and then 12 800 years ago two things
happened at once first a sudden
cataclysmic drop in climate the cold it
gets incredibly cold uh as cold as it
was at the peak of the Ice Age more than
20 000 years ago it gets incredibly cold
but then puzzlingly there's a release of
water into the world ocean I say
puzzlingly because when the earth is
freezing you would not expect melt water
to be going into the world ocean it
should be staying on the ice caps and I
cite the work of cesari Miliani and his
work on the submergence of Bohemian
corals this is how do you know that sea
level Rose there's certain corals that
could only exist within a certain number
of feet of the of the sea surface so
they need the sunlight yeah and when
they drown yeah that tells you the sea
level has risen and they point to a
significance sea level rise twelve
thousand eight hundred years ago at
exactly the moment of this deep freeze
the comet impact hypothesis explains
that because it says that the shock at
the heat of the impact of large
fragments of a comet on the North
American and European ice caps would
have been sufficient to release that
freezing water into the world ocean to
cut the Gulf Stream that's the central
heating system of our planet it's called
the global meridianal overturning
circulation it's these currents of warm
and cold water that flow around the
planet and they the Gulf Stream was cut
and the Earth got extremely cold so I
think the comet impact hypothesis does
best explain that but so just real quick
so comet hits yeah cuts the Gulf Stream
cutting the Gulf Stream across the Gulf
Stream because it releases a huge
quantity of melt water from the North
American ice cap almost instantaneously
so the comet hits the ice yeah that is
in North America and Europe and Europe
that water cuts the Gulf Stream yeah
because it releases all this which was
frozen freezing water gotcha goes into
the world ocean temperature plummets
temperature plummets but at the same
time there's much more potential water
in the oceans so that when the
temperature does rise now you have that
melt water well no so no now we need to
go on 12 800 years ago in the Thousand
or 1 200 years after that that's a
window when all the great Ice Age
megafauna go extinct megaphone are
saber-toothed tiger is woolly mammoths
mastodons giant sloths the whole
collection of of famous Ice Age
megaphone they all go extinct in that
window
um and and clearly the they didn't go
extinct for no reason there's the
cataclysm of the younger dryas that made
the mixture have you seen the oh God
what is the gentleman's name he's a guy
who I believe like excavates up in
Alaska for gold
pretty sure it is I'm forgetting what it
is right now but um
they're like images of woolly mammoths
who have been had like their legs
completely shattered but they're intact
yeah and is this a Boneyard that's been
yes yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
right that that's that's very very very
interesting I've not been there I've not
looked into it yet so I can't speak
authoritatively about it but it might
speak to your opinion right there it's
like what I can't say is that's at
ceradia De lindosa in Colombia there is
an eight kilometer long rock art panel
dated to 12 800 years ago which shows
these megaphone it shows it shows many
of the extinct megaforter from that from
that from that period
um to get back to the point uh so we
have this window of about 1200 years
where the Earth is very cold the
megafauna go extinct but then 11 600
years ago just as fast and dramatically
as the Earth went cold the earth goes
warm you're looking at a 10 degree rise
in global temperatures in in a couple
hundred years it goes a very very in
geological terms very rapid and very
fast and sea level rises very quickly
and what is it called 11 600 years ago
it's it's called melt water pulse 1B
there's another collapse of the ice
sheets and huge amounts of water go into
the world ocean now that that could
realistically be caused by a sudden
burst of solar activity which melted
down those ice sheets but that's not
what I go with I I still prefer the
notion that we're dealing with multiple
bombardments from Comet fragments and in
this case you're looking at a comet
fragment that goes into a world ocean uh
that sends up a huge amount of water
vapor into the upper atmosphere creates
a greenhouse effect and accounts for the
warming that takes place at that time so
two comets one that cool things down and
want to heated things up yeah yeah any
idea why one would cool down and one
would heat up depends where the impact
is if the impact's on an ice cap and
it's releasing enormous amounts of melt
water into the world ocean you've got to
make the world very cold if the impacts
in a world ocean and it's putting a huge
amount of water vapor into the upper
atmosphere it's a greenhouse effect and
the world is going to get warmer it's
all Theory it's not fat all what is fact
is the sudden warming at the end of the
younger driest of the sudden freezing at
the beginning of the year control so
we're searching for explanations for
that we're searching for explanations
I've picked the one I my back but I'm
not claiming that I have to be right
it's that what I do think is really
important is recognizing this was a
global cataclysm it was sustained it
wasn't just a minute it went on for a
thousand years plus uh and it's in our
backyard it's in very relatively recent
human history we're almost at the edge
of history when we go to 11 600 years
ago that's weirdly the date that got
Beckley Tempi in Turkey is built 11 600
years ago that weirdly is the date that
Plato's Timaeus and kritius gives for
the submergence of Atlantis eleven
thousand six hundred years ago before
our time so what's happening to humanity
in this 1200 year window I need to be I
need to be clear about that yeah yeah
um okay because the archaeologists roll
their eyes at any mention of Atlantis if
you even say the word Atlantis or
automatically regarded as a member of
The Lunatic Fringe okay uh and and if
you've even said that word all your work
all the 30 years of work you've done the
Thousand Dives that you've done on
Continental shelves all around world
yeah all of those can be written off
simply because you said the word Atlanta
it's it's flatter for archaeologists
yeah yeah and they they detest the user
now tell us why the Earth is flat
well that's one Theory I definitely
don't bite no no give us the Atlantis
Theory so so the the story of Atlantis
comes down to us from Plato it's
expressed in two dialogues the Timaeus
and the kritias okay Plato was writing
at around 300 BC uh but I come from his
uncle yeah it comes well it's arguably
from a member of his family line who was
the Greek lawmaker Solon Solon yeah yeah
who did make a famous undocumented visit
to Egypt around the year 600 BC and he
was told in Egypt and he was at the
Temple of Neath at seis in the Delta and
there are these inscriptions on the
walls that Temple no longer exists it's
a ruin in the Delta now these writings
on the walls and he asks a priest what
do the writings say and the priest spoke
Greek and ancient Egyptian and he told
so long what the writings say that there
was this great civilization that it was
destroyed in an enormous flood
Plato or Solon refers to it as Atlantis
Atlantis is not an ancient Egyptian word
it looks like some attempt to to
translate into a Greek meaningful Greek
phrase what was originally an ancient
Egyptian phrase and that ancient
Egyptian phrase uh I can tell you pretty
much for sure was the homeland of the
Primeval ones and I'll tell you why in a
minute but but the the point is that
then play Then Solon asks
when did this happen and the priests say
they're very relaxed about it they say
oh 9 000 years ago
so immediately we have a date that we
can put to our calendar 600 BC he makes
the visit 9 000 years before that that's
9600 BC give or take 23 years that is 11
600 years ago that's when Gobekli Tepe
is built that's when melt melt water
plus 1B begins to flood the world oceans
and again my critics will will will
niggle away at the edges of this and say
well melt water pulse 1B unfolded over
three or four hundred years if you
average you doubt it wasn't that much in
any one year but who says it happened to
average rates who says there wasn't a
big rise and then a smaller rise yeah
these these things are very annoying
um but the bottom line is nine thousand
years before so long is 9600 BC that's
the Atlanta State that's Quebec the
tepey's date and then secondly the
Temple of Horus at edfu in Upper Egypt
is very important there's been I worked
with a partial translation
in Upper Egypt it's sort of halfway uh
to to us one uh in southern Egypt it's
this kind of middle this one is the
Quarry I believe that was the Quarry
where they got a lot of the Granite that
they bought there's about 500 kilometers
South but it was a bit further north
than that but it's also on it's also on
the Nile now the Temple of Horus at edfu
is a relatively recent Temple probably
built around 270 BC by the ptolemaic
dynasty of ancient Egypt who these were
Greeks who had overtaken ancient Egypt
but although they colonized ancient
Egypt ancient Egypt colonized their
minds and they became ancient Egyptians
more ancient Egyptian than the ancient
Egyptians themselves in many in many
ways like when white people go to Hawaii
inscribed on the wall of that Temple not
in the language of ancient Egypt as was
spoken 270 BC but in Middle Egyptian
which goes back to about 2000 BC
carefully inscribed then we're informed
that it's based on Temple archives see
that a temple stood there before the
ptolemies rebuilt that Temple and it
stood on the foundations of an even
older Temple the archives were preserved
that's what's inscribed on the walls is
described in Middle Egyptian it's about
2000 BC and it speaks of it tells the
whole Atlantic story it just doesn't
call it Atlantis it speaks of a sacred
Island it calls it the homeland of the
Primeval ones it speaks of a Great
Serpent that comes from the sky and
splits the island in two it speaks of a
huge flood that arises and kills off
almost all the Divine inhabitants apart
from a few survivors who then travel
around the world one of the places they
go to is Egypt and they make their first
business to build primeval Mounds uh in
ancient Egypt there will be the places
the locations of all future temples and
pyramids the and food types are very
clear now I I just need to make this
clear because I relied on Eve Elizabeth
Raymond who was an early translator of
the edford texts okay but recently
the advertex have been completely
translated every single word
into German uh by by a gentleman called
data and and they've translated it all
into German it would be nice if it were
all into English because that's much
more widely spoken what does it say in
Germany
it supports everything in the original
translation there's no there's not a
single part of the original translation
that's debunked by this it supports it
and it adds information that wasn't
there because their reference in those
edfu texts to the destruction of the
homeland of the Primeval ones is seven
thousand years ago but that's in Middle
Egyptian which dates back to 2000 BC so
it goes back to 9000 BC again in 9000
BCS 11 000. it brings us it brings us to
the same date so I I think that
egyptologists have been too hasty to
dismiss real quick so we can just
understand what was said the the snake
that comes down like you said the
Netflix special we can look at comets as
potentially snakes so this comment that
comes and hits the island of Atlantis
that's like a direct shot yes right yeah
but so maybe it doesn't hit exactly the
island but it's hitting close enough
where the effects of that hit are gonna
dramatically dramatically affect the
island
um and remember they didn't close
Atlantis they called it the homeland of
the Primeval and what does that mean the
Primeval ones the ancient ones lived
there that was there that was their
Homeland who created the Mounds who who
then they're survivors
who included seven sages traveled around
the world seeking to rebuild their Lost
Civilization and we heard this and Egypt
was one of the places they went to okay
now some people say that Azores Plateau
might be Atlantis have you ever been
there and maybe we can describe really
quickly where that is well it's in the
Mid-Atlantic um and on the Mid-Atlantic
Ridge the Mid-Atlantic Ridge is
interesting because because there's a
there's a phenomenon called isostasy
isostasy is the earth's surface is a
little bit fluid if you put a if you put
a heavy weight on one bit of it it's
like the end of a seesaw it's going to
force the other bit up so in Britain
um we had an ice cap on Northern
Scotland but right now the Isle of Wight
in the English Channel far to the South
is sinking beneath beneath the beneath
the ocean why is that because the ice
cap on Northern Scotland pushed Northern
Scotland and lifted up the Isle of Wight
since the ice Cap's gone the Isle of
Wight is going back under water you see
this in the islands off of Italy like
Capri yeah is starting to shift and
rotate a little bit yeah it's isostasy
that causes that okay and and isostatic
Rebound in this case and and there is
some indication that the ice cap on
North America may have had effect an
effect on the Mid-Atlantic Ridge and may
have raised it to a higher level than it
was today oh so wait a minute but I'm
not I I need to be clear I'm not looking
for Atlantis there or anywhere I don't
think there was one location every every
story and reference and I don't think we
should be looking for a genetic location
for it either right just as just as it
would be really hard to look for a
genetic location of America today the
U.S U.S culture is a Multicultural
Society there's the multi-ethnicity
society I suspect quote unquote Atlantis
was like that I suspect that it was all
over the world that it used that it that
it occupied the best real estate on
Earth the the lands that are now under a
few hundred feet of water yeah caused by
if we knew where it was we could at
least look for some sort of remains if
there were if if there was a definite
Heartland for it I think we should be
looking for those remains on the flooded
Continental shelves all around the world
and that's what I spent seven years of
my life doing uh was was diving on the
Continental shelves and finding again
and again ruins and structures that
weren't supposed to be there I think
there's the whole story of humanity
that's that's missing uh underwater and
I would while I'm saying that I I I
would like to give credit to archeology
just there is some work now being done
Marine archeology which isn't any longer
just looking for shipwrecks from the
medieval period or even from the 20th
century about 19th century but but ship
but but are looking at the flooded
Continental shells and it's just
starting this this work should have been
happening for decades it's just
beginning uh I think that's going to
reveal a a great deal and I know it's
going to reveal a great deal because I
found a great deal but I want to add
that the Amazon rainforest and the
Sahara Desert are also underserved by
archeology yes and we can't claim that
there was no Lost Civilization of the
Ice Age while there's so much of the
world we never looked at at all
especially the Sahar desert right
because there could be fascinating
thousands of pyramids just covered in
mounds of sand right now they're really
good we are finding a lot in the Amazon
yes
I work in the Amazon is is fascinating
okay I want to hope to be back in the
Amazon within the next few months